die frage ist macht die regierung jetzt
genügend um eben die versorgung der
bürger den wohlstand der bürger zu
sichern herr sarrazin ist dass ihr
eindruck also letztlich um musik man
muss ja vorne das unterscheiden was habe
ich jetzt als als also verteilungsfrage
und das muss vernünftig geregelt werden
ich warte ab was da rauskommt es ist
jedenfalls keine gute politik alle 14
tage irgendein anderes instrument zu
haben was immer am ziel vorbei geht da
wird das benzinpreis ermäßigt vereinigt
das zentrale problem da kommt das dann
nur ein euro ticket freue mich für jeden
der billig bahn fährt war aber auch
nicht das zentrale problem zusätzlich im
bahnfahren jetzt anzuregen in dieser
lage und jetzt kommt wieder etwas und
ist auch nicht das zentrale problem und
irgendwann fühlt sich der bürger
veräppelt dach wenn die sonne so viel
geld für dinge haben die gibt es
eigentlich gar nicht nötig sei könnten
sind eigentlich auch mal was für mich
haben und das und das sorgt dann für
einen unmut die man dann auch wieder
rational beherrschen muss und dann wird
dann vierter fünfter sechster instrument
kommen und das ist natürlich ein
absoluter ihre weg man muss jetzt zwei
fragen lösen sie löse ich das einkommens
problem
einer bestimmten gruppe 8 bis 12
millionen menschen schätze ich mal und
und wie gehe ich um mit der verdauungs
lage auch denen den wir jetzt geld geben
hilft ja nichts wenn die wenn die
wohnung kalt bleibt und übrigen wir
haben auch schon also camping gaskocher
noch aus alten kämpen im keller mit
diesen mit diesen blauen mit diesen
blauen patronen den hamburg es
also schon mal zu mal überprüft ob man
noch funktioniert und er tut ist so das
ist also schon mal beruhigen und da
stellt man sich sowas hin da kann man
sagt ehrlich gesagt hätte
ich auch schon den gaskocher aus gewesen
zu machen dann zusätzlich gerade ruhiger
dem café cuba aber jetzt und jetzt diese
versorgungslücke wenn die auf und zu
kommt und da warte ich wirklich auf eine
antwort der politik dem mir fehlt es
auch mangels nach nähe ganz oft muss
sterne meiner gegenwärtigen weil ich
jetzt wie ich das beantworten soll was
passiert denn wenn jetzt irgendwann
mitte september das gas ganz hört auf zu
laufen da kommt die industrie gebraucht
ihre prozesswärme da kommen die werte
dann ausfällt dann sag ich wieder um
einen alten vorschlag pullover anziehen
15 grad aber wer das nicht tut dann
weiter mit 21 grad heißt wir können wir
auch nicht daran hindern so und wie geht
die politik mit dieser süd für uns ganz
einfach wie die politik mitunter
sarrazin die gibt er uns nämlich einfach
ratschläge wie wir sparen können wie
kommt es bei ihnen zum beispiel an frau
lindemann also wenn sie dann aber
gehören jetzt herrn kretschmann hören
der sagt 'mensch von lindemann nehmen
sie doch nach schlappen sie müssen nicht
so auf duschen genau von dem total schön
war ja hab ich da was hat ihnen betrifft
hat ja überhaupt nicht er friert nicht
er wird nicht frieren er hat ja auch
noch sagte er auch so offen aber nehmen
sie jetzt öfter den waschlappen
den haben wir anscheinend gewählt habe
ich so festgestellt nate findet eine
katastrophe und auch die sanktion finde
ich scheiße die helfen weder der ukraine
noch hört er kriegt dadurch oft wenn wir
sprechen nur uns eigentlich schaden wir
nur unserem volk ich finde ein
schwachsinn ich möchte gerne weiter
laufen lassen sind gas und rohöl und da
sehen immer mehr deutsche sowie auch
eine umfrage vom freitag von den
kollegen von rtl zeigt anlass war die
äußerung von wolfgang kubicki der sagt
'mensch ich hatte die lösung lasst
einfach nord und zwei jetzt aufmachen
das sichert unsere gasversorgung das ist
ihr parteikollege
cookies meine partei kollege ja auch ein
comic kann man auch daran erinnern dass
80 prozent von nord stream 1 gerade
nicht genutzt werden das weiß er wir
haben keine pipeline problem ist ja
jetzt nicht so dass er das nicht wüsste
naja wenn sie können gerne fragen also
wir haben gefragt haben der weiß dass
das ist für sie ja wir haben keine
pipeline problem die kapazität ist ja
auch jetzt schon da wir haben am anderen
ende der pipeline ein problem und das
ist derjenige der nicht genug gas durch
liefert denn deutschland hat ja keine
sanktionen wenn es um den import von gas
gibt sondern offensichtlich nur wenn es
um ihn ist das muss man bei herr
rupprecht würden sie das als eine lösung
schritt nach vorne sehen nord stream
zwei aufmachen und zu sagen okay wir
verabschieden uns davon volle
solidarität mit der ukraine zu üben ja
wir gucken auf uns auf unsere
gasversorgung immer mehr deutsche sehen
das ja offenbar so also ich weiß jetzt
auch nicht genau was am anderen seite
eine anderen seite der leitung ist es
war ja die turbine angegeben worden bei
nordstream einst als ursache dass man
jetzt nicht genug liefern kann mag
richtig sein kann ich nicht beurteilen
sie wurde jetzt geliefert da gab es dann
auch wieder irgendwelche schwierigkeiten
ich weiß nicht ob mein nord stream zwei
jetzt eine andere turbine schon
bereitsteht ob das so weit fertig ist
dass man dann wieder mehr durch pusten
könnte davon verstehe ich also weiß ich
wirklich nicht